you know
in uh mixed martial arts sometimes it's
like in science something you can make a
mess
like a mistake you know like every human
can make mistakes you know
there's certain sport or a certain
situation that you
if there's a mistake made you're you're
you're that's it exactly sometimes it's
the case in mma
but sometimes you able to redeem
yourself
and uh if you look at the fight with bj
penn
one that i had which was probably one of
the most competitive fight i
and it was probably the it was the fight
that i got the most
damage and i was messed up it took me
three days
like two three days to recuperate from
that fight i was really damaged
and my first fight versus my second
fight i made a lot of adjustment
because i i've learned from my first
fight and also i had a guy
one thing people don't know like they
talk about fighters having secret
weapons
see for me my secret weapons was not
like some is that they used like certain
like different things for me it was
knowledge had a guy
in material he was measuring frames he's
not a scientist is
he's a friend of of uh ferrous and i and
what he does he
watch fight and he measure frames the
way he does it is when
you watch a fight and one of the guy
throw a punch he
he cut the picture by frame the video by
frame
so he's able to see which fighter has
better reaction time than others
and bjpen he found out that bj penn
evolved the
ufc roster at the time when he was in
his prime he had probably the best
reaction time of all
according to him lyoto mashido was the
second one
but bj penn was the first one so
i knew that if i would try to go first
because i always been the fastest guy
normally when i fight someone but when i
fought big japan i tried to go
first and he was always able to like
i never was never able to to touch him
with my jab and he came back with a
counter punch
however because of what he told me
i knew that japan has a very fast
reaction time but had a very poor
reset time to him the way he described
it to me is like your nervous system is
like a muscle
bj pen was so fast but he's like more
like a sprinter
so what i did the second fight i when i
fought with japan i made him flinch
like i faked a lot so i make him react
and flinch so all that that reaction
time
that he used to flinch was not used
properly to avoid my punches so he i
burn
i i load up his his nervous system with
a lot of information
and fit and fake and to make him flinch
and pretending i was kicking and
wrestling
so he got overwhelmed and he got tired
very very fast
so that's how i beat him people
sometimes they don't know really what's
the strategy behind
the thing they only see the physical
part but when you fight someone if i
fight you i look at you in the eyes
there's a lot of things that going on
between you and i
i can look down here pump jab you in the
face
the audience will not see this little
detail
but you will see it and that's what it
makes the magic
during a fight the relation that you
have with the opponent you know like
like the mental game what you you make
him believe
those little things i use a lot of those
if you
talk to a lot of my opponent they'll
tell you like i use a lot of these
little thing you know like i look down a
banana i go i go up or i'm pretending
i want to attack you so i'm i'm make you
flinch but in reality i'm just doing
this
because i want to rest i want to
recuperate and i'm tired how much is you
know people talk about that with poker
for example how much is the value of
this
you know so like some people argue that
poker is more about the betting
you know it's just the money it's just
how much you bet and so on
so that would be more like uh the
analogy there with
with fighting would be just strictly the
physical movement of your body
and then a lot of people argue that
there's a lot here in the way you look
in the little movements in the face
so do you think there's do you think
you're communicating
with your opponent when you look at them
there's no way to know
for sure 100 and i'm by no no mean
psychic nothing like that and i don't
believe in that at all the only thing is
i know to
looking through the eyes of my opponent
when he's afraid
and when he gives up on me yeah i've
been accused very often
in my career to not take enough risk to
not
finish my opponent but the reason why i
didn't finish my opponent is because
i saw in his eyes that he gave up he
gave me the fight and i'm winning the
fight
so it's not up to me
it's not to me to make it to try to
sacrifice myself trying to finish him
perhaps if i do that i will open up from
for him to
to to capitalize on my mistake
it's up to him to make a risk so
people sometimes they they don't
understand that this is the art of
fighting my friend you know
like if i'm winning the fight like in
aki and isaac
if you're winning the game and it's the
third period
it's at the end of the third period
you're not gonna take out your
goaltender trying to score another goal
because winning uh
five to three or five to four is the
same thing
same thing in mma we make a living out
of this and sometimes
you know as sad as bad as it can be you
want to save yourself for another day
you know you want to minimize
the damage but if he knows he's losing
the fight
it's up to you him to take the risk it's
not up to me
so i'm having i'm a good counter fighter
i use a lot of my attack or counter
strike or reactive techno proactive
takedown
that's my specialty so i'm not gonna i
i'd have no desire to sacrifice myself
trying to to trying to finish my
opponent if he want to
if if perhaps i might give him the
opportunity to capitalize on me
it's it's not it's not smart to do that
and very often when i fight someone i
can read him i see the fear in his eyes
now i'm like i
got you now he's very desperate that
doesn't mean i have to
put my guard down because he's gonna
he's gonna be desperate but i know i'm
beating you
and i know i'm beating you i'm just
gonna do what i need you know if i have
a chance of course i'll knock him out
but i'm not gonna
try to sacrifice myself to knock you out
and if you do that maybe one day you'll
make a mistake and
you'll get dropped and you're you'll
you'll tell yourself i shoot
i just got brain damage maybe i'm never
gonna come back the same maybe you know
i i ruined my character or
you know it's a it's a very serious game
that we're playing it's very dangerous
in the face of that
risk i mean uh mike tyson talked about
you know when the opponent looks away he
knows he's got him
right that uh that he's broken
for a person like me who has trouble
making eye contact with people
there's there's truth to that i mean
there there's truth to that
that there's there's an animal nature to
us looking away
i mean you could see that the way the
body language the way the eyes move
between two animals going at it
uh in in the wild on like two lions
fight or
do whatever fight there's a certain
beta move when you've you've been
defeated
yes or one thing when i know that that
when it happened one of the sign is when
i just like
make a faint and the guy flinched like
crazy that's mean he's really scared of
me
it's a little bit like you're you're
you're you're doing this that guy flinch
a little bit or you're doing this he's
flying like
that that's mean you hurt him and he
doesn't want to get hurt again so he
is he's really trying to run away and
not not winning the fight anymore but
not
losing sort of surviving the the five
round and it's hard to
to finish a guy who does doesn't want to
fight
a guy who's not fighting anymore to win
and he's fighting to not lose
and the proof of that if you don't
believe me just look the reign of all
the greatest champion in ufc
uh i don't care who they are jon jones
or
uh like you could clearly see that in
the beginning of their rank they could
you know finish a lot of their opponents
saying same as me in the beginning i was
finishing alone
but there's a time that the entire ufc
roster is studying
you and they found ways to perhaps not
beating you but they find a way to
navigate to
the the fight in a way that they
minimize the damage you know what i mean
so it's a big difference between
fighting to win and fighting to not lose
you